hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from uh round four of
the ftx crypto cup it is round four or
rather game four uh of the match lavon
are you on versus pragnanda uh and levon
lost in game three so now he needs a win
to bounce back into the match and they
will repeat a variation uh they played
in game two uh which is a really wild
one uh levon had a winning position uh
prague sacrifice that tried to sacrifice
a bishop on g3 but even if you haven't
seen game two i will talk about it in
this game as it's quite similar but much
much different so let's dive straight
into it can levon bounce back uh he
opens again with c4 he goes for the
english opening and prague continues
with e5 he had a very very risky
position but of course after game two he
checked with the engine and uh
you know during break time and he found
what uh what he messed up so obviously
he improved on that but let's see how he
does knight to c3 we have knight to f6
and knight to f3 the um
still the english opening three knights
are developed and now e4 chasing away
the knight knight to g5 and now pawn to
c6 we have knight capture sunny for
grabbing that pawn knight captures
knight captures and now pawn to d5 so
it's upon sacrifice but black is getting
uh
a whole lot of development and i think
after
these two games between levon and prague
uh it will become very very popular i i
i think adiban even played it in the
olympiad uh so c captures on the 5c
captures knights to g3 and now h5 a very
very
crude idea but it seems like it is
working so here ponte e3 h4 and not
knight back to e2 we have knights the c6
by prague and pawn to d4 and they are
still repeating everything they played
in game two of their match queen to f6
and now
uh in the first game level one played
knight to c3 but here he deviates and
goes uh bishop to d2 so it is now as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game uh prague continues with bishop to
d6 as he did in game two we have pawn to
a3 and now bishop to f5 the bishops
nicely developed so you can see that
this is definitely very very active play
from black and you get it uh for the
price of only one pawn rook the c1 by 11
and now rook to d8 we have knight to c3
and now uh queen to g6 henry in the
development of the light square bishop
putting pressure on the g2 pawn and also
preparing pawn to h3 so queen f3 and
again ponte h3 saying
okay do you do maybe want to capture
here but if you capture then your entire
pawn structure is messed up for example
uh characters black will play something
like queen to e6 and then uh white
really doesn't know what to do with the
king you you're not castling queen side
you're not castling king side your king
is in the center of the board so it's uh
not the greatest of positions also
knight capture sunday for already a
threat so
not the best so here g3 uh levon uh
pushes the pawn like he did in game two
and now bishop to g4 attacking the queen
and basically forcing lavon to play
queen captures on d5 and put the queen
in front of the rook but there is
nothing better and this is uh kind of
what levon did uh in game
two but uh in game two i believe the
pawn was still on g2 and but here the
point is you don't have any good
discoveries let's say you play bishop
captures on g3 yes you open up a
discovery to the wine queen but it's not
a problem queenie for check and you just
force a a queen trade captures captures
now the bishop is hanging once the
bishop
uh moves back we're gonna play bishop to
e2 and you know it's a much much better
position for white and now the problem
is let's say you play something knight
to e7
rook c to g1 uh you have problems uh you
have problems defending the b7 pawn you
have problems defending the g7 pawn so
it's uh i it's just a very tricky
position to play but plus you're down a
pawn and the white will be winning this
in the long run so instead we have
castles here uh progress castles to
safety now still olive one has to uh you
know worry about his queen so he just
moves the queen queen to b5 we have rook
f the e8 aligning the rook with the king
here so you have to be careful knight
captures and d4 might be an option so
bishop to e2 and now it seems like
knight captures on d4 is no longer an
option since of course the knight can be
captured the bishop is now preventing
the roof from delivering check but that
this is exactly what proc plays he plays
knight captures on d4 e captures and now
the spectacular rook captures on e2 you
have to capture with the knight
otherwise you're gonna lose the queen so
knight captures an e2 and now queen to
e4 this is what proc found uh now the
idea is that the rook on h1 is hanging
and how do you defend this if you come
to the material now uh levon is up a
full rook and i mean that's of course
completely winning if uh
if he could castle the safety of course
he cannot castle if he castles he just
gets checkmated so that's not an option
the problem is you can't really play a
move like rook to g1 it's uh just dead
lost for for uh levon because the queen
is needed on this diagonal to defend the
knight and a simple a6 wins the game for
prague here you have to move the queen
somewhere c4 is the only square that
keeps an eye on the knight but now b5
and that's it queen has to move and of
course we deliver checkmate uh so uh
levon really needs to figure out what to
play after prague uh place this queen
the e4 move and the best way to defend
is bishop to e3 uh but levon plays
bishop to g5 which is similar uh but uh
not quite the same as now the e file uh
is still open with the bishop on e3
there's still one more piece in front
you know in between the queen and the
white king
but now there is a move that prague can
play that gives him a winning position
but it's not an easy one to find so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the only winning idea for prague
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting
this incredible incredible uh trick in
the position and uh for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is rook
to e8 and now you see uh what is
happening so we moved the rook away from
d8 where the bishop was attacking it
because if you just went for queen
counters on h1 which of course is
possible uh then king d2 now your queen
is hanging you're gonna play queen
captures on h2 now bishop captures on d8
uh and not now probably lose this bishop
let's say queen captures an f2 but now
you have this sorry not that queen to e8
with check and once the king moves
there's queen to e4 with check and now
the bishop will hang otherwise uh
you have to defend it otherwise it will
hang so f5 blocking and defending the
bishop and now queen e3 offers a queen
trade and now every move loses for
prague here except queen to g2 now would
this be found would this be played
i believe most likely
but still it looks like it's completely
winning for black but you know
engines are like that they just say
everything is perfectly fine you can
play this but prague doesn't go for this
even though it seems to be completely
winning instead after this bishop the g5
move uh
uh rook to e8 incredible incredible
precision by prague and now you're just
threatening to win material here just
queen captures an e2 there's a triple
attack on the knight and also queen
captures on h1 now is a possibility uh
but levon goes back bishop to e3 and now
he asks are you still interested in
capturing this rook and still it's not
the greatest of moves because if queen
captures now king d2 and the queen back
to e4 it seems like you've just repeated
you've defended your knight as the queen
uh the rook as the queen is at attacking
the rook but now knight c3 and all of a
sudden white is back in the game there
is no clear way of how to continue you
can't go back and go after the h2 pawn
because the rook is hanging so here uh
lavon would come back into the game but
prague of course plays the strongest
pawn to a6 beautiful stuff queen to a
for now pawn to b5 and now the queen
is cut off from the defense of the
knight and also from attacking the rook
on e8 so queen captures an a6 and now
finally prague plays queen captures on
h2
which incredible as uh as this game is
is not the strongest move so it seems
like this rook can never be captured i
will just show you because it's a lot of
fun queen f3 wins here for black uh as
it threatens checkmate and there's no
good way to defend it if you play queen
characters on b5 to defend like this
then there's this very nasty rook
captures an e3 move and after f captures
now you play queen captures on h1 and
after king to d2 now queen captures an
h2 and now you have nothing to worry
about you don't have this uh problem of
your rook hanging on e8 and you have a
passport on h2 you're just gonna move
the queen uh white really doesn't have
all that many options also the knight
here is in a bit of a pickle uh so the
queen can't really go anywhere and
you're just to win this very very easily
but there is a better defense after
queen to f3 you could play rook to c2
the this also defends against checkmate
but now there's this incredible bishop
captures on g3 the move that prague
played in game two and wanted to play in
game four
but never got around to do it because
now of course um you cannot capture if
you capture them the bishop is no longer
defended and then everything just opens
up but if h captures then we play queen
captures an h1 king to d2 now h2 and now
of course you will move your queen and
then queen the h pawn even if rook c1 we
happily captured the queen captures
knight captures h1 queen and now you're
just up material you have a rook against
the knight and of course a completely
winning position you can attack the the
king is wide open on d2 so uh queen f3
of course is winning but prague was
extremely low on time here he had like
30 seconds on the clock and levon had
like 10 minutes on the clock so prague
played queen captures on h1 came to d2
and now queen to f3 again putting
pressure on the knight
so rook to e1 defending uh queen to f6
prague goes back with the queen and now
knight the c3 and this is what we've
discussed if you take your time to pick
up the rook to bring the queen back into
the game uh you know you might just uh
allow levon back into the game and
knight the c3 is a very important move
here if you don't play this let's say
bishop b4 check and uh off goes the
queen from a6 so knight's the c3
blocking any checks from the dark square
bishop and now we have queen to e6 by
prague uh queen the c6 now uh putting
pressure on the rook now if the queen
ever moves and now rook the c8 attacking
the queen queen to d5 offering a trade
of queens and now uh prague can't really
trade queens if he trades he allows
lavon back into the game and he is uh up
upon so it will be levon who will be
pushing for a win so prague plays none
other than pawn to b4 yeah incredible
stuff now you can't trade queens because
b captures on c3 comes with check so we
uh we win material here so a captures on
b4 and now prague just moves the queen
queen to f6 but at least now he has the
he has opened up the a file that can be
used for attack so here pawn to b5 levon
starts advancing his newly created pass
pawn bishop to b for now uh we have rook
to a1 now not allowing a proc to utilize
the a file and now bishop to f3 also
here if rook t8 is played if the rules
get traded off uh of course prague has
nothing more to look for in this game so
bishop f3 attacking the queen keeping an
eye on the a8 square and queen to b3 now
attacking the bishop here bishop back
all the way to f8 now even if the rook
moves rook to a8 at least will not come
with check so b6 uh lavon continues
advancing his past pawn and it seems
like uh levon is about to beat prague
and get back into the match uh so bishop
the b7 stopping the pass pawn and now
pawn to d5 now lemon starts advancing
his other pawn we have bishop to c5 and
here levon seems to have started playing
uh overly defensive here rook to a for
rook to a7r very very active moves even
uh shifting the king over to e2 are are
possible moves but even though levon had
like 10 minutes on the clock he wanted
to beat prague on time as prague had 30
seconds and he wanted really uh proc the
thing fast to not have enough time to uh
you know uh calculated every everything
but this seems to have gone uh yeah to
proc's favor as he calculates everything
so rook to e1 uh and now comes uh just a
nice bishop captures on e3 f captures on
e3 levon even gets an improved uh pawn
structure in the center now if this pawn
starts marching forward it's going to be
very good for him but now comes bishop
to a6 and now uh all of a sudden uh
it's not so clear once the queen f2
check comes the e2 square is covered uh
the the rook controlling the c file this
king might get checkmated and okay like
i said lebron had plenty of time he
could have calculated that he's
perfectly fine
but he played queen to c2
and now he just blunders the b6 pawn
incredible stuff so prague very happily
captures it and now we have king to c1
but now his position uh went from
winning to the well maybe not
considerably worse but definitely not
very enjoyable uh bishop to c4 now proc
stops pawn to b3 if b3 and king c2 then
white is still okay but here uh prague
just wants to play bishop to b3 control
this diagonal and then maybe put the
rook on a8 play rook to a1 so there are
options here for black so rook to d1
levon again plays a couple of worst
moves in a row this is just incredible
probably playing against prague's time
but prague is just out playing him uh
even though they're playing extremely
fast so bishop to b3 now this just wins
material for prague queen to f2 and now
queen the a5 even not grabbing material
just uh preparing rook captures and c3
uh this is beautiful stuff levon plays
king to d2 he defends against this idea
uh but now probably just plays rook
captures on c3 and he was in this
position and move 44 that levon aaron
resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you just lost
a piece and after you recapture the
problem is there's queen captures and e5
check and now the rook will be captured
and the rook will be defended for
example king c1 queen captures on d1
checking the b2 now just bishop a4 and
of course here uh up a full piece uh
there's no way for white to play this
so brilliant brilliant stuff by prague
uh levon again got a completely winning
position against prague in this
variation like he did in game two but it
would seem that this variation of the
english or rather this uh counter on the
english defense is so so uh incredible
this f4 this uh e4 idea uh and the just
after knight g5 uh sacrificing this pawn
is so strong that even a a super
brilliant and creative player like lavon
ariana couldn't find his way around this
uh against um
against prague uh like i said with 10
minutes on the clock against prox 30
seconds this was incredible to watch so
if you if you have time to check out the
the live feed as well uh but the just uh
i believe that this with d5 that this
variation although it's a known one uh
will become very very popular in online
chess now so if you face the english
make sure to try it out and you know
if it goes your way you can uh
enjoy it more uh so yeah that's the game
and the match hope you guys enjoyed it
the first two games ended in a draw then
prague just uh you know okay game three
was uh complete annihilation but game
four again uh like i said leveling uh
got a winning advantage and then uh pr
truck just won
and these are the standings after uh
after this round so you can see that
magnus and prague are still leading the
tournament both of them are on 100 both
of them on 12 points they have won all
four of their matches uh followed by
alireza with eight levon with five young
sister of duda and danish guru with four
liam lay with three and hans uh niemann
with zero points still but you know
there are still two more rounds to go
maybe it will be his day
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it and that uh you uh maybe
found a a favorite weapon of your own uh
against the english opening uh i would
like to thank johan clason and raymond
rafael uh
uh
usher uh and uh uh michael uh zakarias
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the ftx crypto cup uh until
it finishes uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day